mes chers collègues ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre déléguée
chargée des personnes handicapées madame
la ministre pour commencer je voudrais
que not associer notre groupe à la
douleur de la famille et des proches du
jeune Thomas que nous partageons depuis
6 ans nous agissons pour obtenir
soutenir les professionnels du secteur
du handicap la mission d'accompagnement
des travailleurs en AAT vers des
parcours professionnels c'est ainsi
considérablement renforcé ces dernières
années le projet de loi plein emploi
voté il y a 2 semaines permettra aux
travailleurs handicapés en AAT de
bénéficier de l'essentiel des droits
individuels et collectifs des salariés
par ces mesures nous offrons aux
personnes en situation de handicap la
possibilité de s'autodéterminer et
facilitons leur recherche d'emploi en
milieu ordinaire j'ai cependant été
alerté madame la ministre notamment par
Estia 78 du fait que mon département des
ivelines est l'un de ceux les moins bien
dotés en foyer de vie ou médicalisés
pour personnes en situation de handicap
leur inquétude que je partage est grande
sur l'avenir des établissements qu'il
gère avec et vous le savez
professionnalisme et dévouement je sais
madame ministre que vous n'en doutez
absolument pas cependant en faisant
converger les droits des travailleurs
des zates vers ceux des salariés le
gouvernement fait peser sur ces
établissements le financement de ces
dispositifs qu'ils auront du mal à
supporter dans les Yvelines pour les 16
établissement d'Estia 78 c'est un
déficit de près de 400000 € annuels qui
est envisagé risque de fermeture n'est
donc pas exclure ce qui rendrait les
personnes qui travaillent sans
accompagnement et sans emploi ainsi
madame la ministre quel solution le
gouvernement comp-il mettre en place
pour répondre à ses inquiétudes et ainsi
garantir dans les ivelines comme
ailleurs la pérennité de
l'accompagnement par le travail des
Français en situation de handicap je
vous remercie